[Musik]
hey leute heute gibt es ein ganz
besonderes video wie ihr vielleicht
schon gemerkt habt haus des geldes ist
endlich da mit einer neuen staffel und
wir lieben haus des geldes will lieben
ist also ich find ich bin schon
eifersüchtig auf die leute die die erste
und zweite stock nicht geguckt haben und
dieses wissen einfach noch nicht haben
was alles passiert und ich werde mir
glaube ich die ersten zweite staffel
auch noch mal angucken ist habe ich
glaube ich ein zwei tag schaffen wir
doch oder hansa an einem tag bevor die
dritte staffel anfängt und wir uns die
erstmal einfach komplett reinziehen und
herbert heute mache ich dafür zur feier
des tages eine fondant orte dafür habe
ich schon so ein bisschen was
vorbereitet ich habe meine bis gebilden
gefragt und ich habe sie durch geteilt
ich habe gerne zubereitet und die böden
befüllt und anschließend von außen
eingestrichen wollte das video jetzt
nicht zu lang gestalten deswegen habe
ich das alles im vorfeld vorbereitet und
das ist jetzt das endergebnis
und an dieser stelle machen wir weiter
die ist jetzt schlimm dort eingestrichen
ich habe hier dafür einmal roten von
dank wie knete ich jetzt ganz kurz weich
und dann werde ich ihn einmal ganz dünn
ausrollen
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt die von der decke richtig
schön dünn ausgerollt kann es nämlich
nicht leiden wenn er so dick ist wobei
ich schaffe den immer runter wenn ich
kuchen es um ehrlich zu sein
ja und ich habe jetzt hier die torte mit
ghanas natürlich eingestrichen wir
brauchen ja eine unterlage damit der von
land nicht durchfeuchtet und ghanas oder
buttercreme ist eben das beste ich
schreibe euch aber alle genauen infos in
der infobox damit ich euch eben hier das
video nicht zu lang mache und ich habe
jetzt ein bisschen back translate jetzt
ist nämlich sehen
es ist total trocken jetzt hier durch
die schokolade das mache ich hier ein
bisschen back trends bei obendrauf
wenn ihr jetzt nur öl nehmen würdet mit
dem pinsel dass wir einfach zu viel
das kann man viel besser dosieren und
jetzt gebe ich ganz vorsichtig die vom
land decke drauf und macht es richtig
schön glatt auch an den seiten
[Musik]
die torte richtig schön glatt an der
oberfläche an den seiten und kupfer man
braucht diese von land letter gar nicht
ich hab auch irgendwo im keller ein
zum frühjahr aber eigentlich geht man
braucht nur klappt ja welche händler
voraus
im besten fall keine horne und ansonsten
spiele machen und wir arbeiten jetzt nur
anhand dieser vorlage und ihr müsst
darauf achten macht die also der ich
jetzt einfach aus dem internet gezogen
falls euch wundert wo die her ist florin
ja dann setzen wir mal rein und dann
könnt ihr einfach nur noch darauf achten
dass die wirklich auf die torte passt
nicht zu groß und jetzt nehmen wir uns
und unseren hautfarbenen von dann ich
habe den übrigens hier immer komplett
fertig schon ich habe den jetzt nicht
selber ein gehabt ich finde es ein
bisschen einfacher wenn die dann eben
schon fertig sind und jetzt wollen wir
uns den auch ganz dünn aus übrigens
könnt ihr immer ein bisschen becker
stärke untendrunter geben weil wenn er
zum beispiel puderzucker oder normale
speisestärke nimmt dann ist das so
klumpig und dann sieht man die eben auch
später auf dem konto deswegen nämlich
immer becker stärke
jetzt nimmt ihr euch eure vorlage liegt
sie einfach drauf und nimmt euch dann
ein sehr scharfes messer oder ein
skalpell und dann schneidet ihr einfach
aus und genau so machen wir weiter das
zeigen soll ich dann gleich in kurzen
schritten mit den augenbrauen mit dem
bad mit der nase die augen genau so
machen wir das und wenn denn alles
fertig ist dann geht es weiter
[Musik]
ich habe der maske jetzt noch die
schwarzen haare verfasst das ging auch
ganz einfach ich könnte auch wieder
diese vorlage nehmen ein bisschen
schwarzen von land aus rollen und dann
nehmt ihr euch ganz einfach ein messer
aber nicht die gezackte weite sondern
die rückseite einfach nur mit dem
messerrücken daran das ist total easy
und jetzt brauchen wir ja was für drum
herum denn die tragen ja nicht nur
dieses salvador dalí maske die
verbrecher sein ich mag die haben ja
auch noch diesen umhang mit der mütze
und das versuchen wir jetzt nach zu
kreieren und da finde ich mir ein ganz
langes stück roten von land und schneide
mir darf zwei ganz lange strenge aus ich
zeig euch das mal ja das erkläre ich
jetzt dir und natürlich auch den anderen
diskussionen und das ist küchenrolle die
habe ich einfach in stücke gerissen und
hier nochmal zwischen diesen umhang
gemacht haben uns daher gerade zwei
dünne strenger ausgerollt und das ist
quasi jetzt die kapuze und damit das
jetzt so eine kleine schöne optik
bekommt und das nicht so flach aufs
gesicht liegt sag ich mal habe ich da
jetzt einfach ein bisschen küchenpapier
rein gemacht und so darf das jetzt aus
herten am ende auch noch hier den
überschuss ganz einfach wegschneiden und
ich finde dann sich das auch wunderbar
aus ja und vor allem ohne hilfsmittel
und rucki zucki das geht jetzt auch
richtig schnell und in der zwischenzeit
machen wir jetzt noch reißverschlüsse in
schwarz 1 habe ich schon gemacht
brauchen ja ein lange und einen kurzen
und ich zeige euch jetzt mal wie ich das
mache komplett ohne silikon um die es ja
auch gibt bereits verschlüsse aber so
selten jemanden das macht muss man sich
das nicht extra anschaffen
deshalb nehme ich hier einfach so ein
bisschen schwarzen von dann und rollt im
dünn aus und jetzt nehme ich mir eine
tankkarte oder ihr könnt zum beispiel
auch ein lineal nehmen und habt ihr
nämlich sind schön geraten strang
genauso jetzt gehe ich noch einmal in
der mitte entlang aber nicht komplett
durchschneiden
aber das war nicht ganz die mitte
deshalb schneide ich hier noch
so und jetzt nehmt ihr euch wieder ein
scharfes messer oder ein skalpell und
dann macht ihr hier einfach nur sehr
steifen rein da und wir sind fertig und
ich weiß nicht warum ich sehr komisch
rede ist ziemlich heißen der maske also
respekt an die die das schaffen damit
eine bank auszurauben
und ich habe jetzt hier noch damit das
ganze komplett ist und schön fertig
aussieht noch einmal die schrift
ausgedruckt das geht genau so wie nach
dem prinzip der maske gedruckt euch
einfach das logo aus hier und schneidet
es dann aus die einzelnen buchstaben und
dann ganz einfach auch von land mit dem
skalpell oder mit einem scharfen messer
ausschneiden und 1 wollte schon immer
mal machen genau das hier alles klappt
na ja auf jeden fall habe ich mir noch
hier so ein bisschen geld angespart drei
dafür ganz schön hart arbeiten und ich
finde das sieht einfach toll aus
verdammt egal es kommt das gleiche
hinaus ländern schön viel geld und somit
ist die torte fertig und geschmacklich
muss ich sagen wir haben ja wann den
libeskind boden und schoko granat und
leute vanille und schoko wer mag dieser
kombi nicht ob jemand und vielleicht
könnt ihr mir in die kommentare
schreiben
wer sein lieblingscharakter war welcher
war deine schlau war der professor sein
vater er hatte plan a bis z alles durch
genau dann wo man dachte und verdammt
die fliegen auf hat der professor wieder
plan in der tasche gehabt richtig gehen
ja ich fand tokio ganz cool ich
verdienen richtig sympathisch und
generell wenn unsere ja weil sie auch
die sprecherin und was sie echt
bemerkenswert finde essen wir eigentlich
voll die schwerverbrecher
man fand die alle so sympathisch und
wollte dass sie diese bank ausräumen
können bzw
dieses geld drucken können es ist echt
heftig heimlich schlau gemacht die
produzenten naja würde auch nicht wollen
aber vielleicht gibt's ja noch jemanden
der ist noch nicht gesehen hat was
überhaupt nicht glaube dass er jetzt
oder und ja was ich noch sagen wollte
bild so relativ wichtig ist das heißt
keine kooperation denn sachen die hummer
und ich feiern und cool finden da machen
wir auch gerne gratis werbung und warten
jetzt nicht unbedingt auf eine
kooperation geholfen dass ihr das jetzt
nach macht alle wichtigen infos stehen
in der video beschreibung zutaten infos
zu den rezepten infos zum fondant alles
mögliche schaut da rein
schickt eure fotos mit dem hashtag
dieses kitchen postet sie noch besser
auf instagram und facebook das bleibt
mir dann noch natürlich mit den ab oder
lassen werde das hingeguckt
weil ihr weil wir das halt auch wirklich
feiern und warum sollte man jetzt echt
aus einer kooperation aufbauen also muss
nicht sein
also wir verabschieden uns und wünschen
euch noch einen wunderschönen tag
abonnieren nicht vergessen in
deutschland nicht vergessen und bis zum
nächsten letztlich das geht schon tschüs
[Musik]